à une autre mission réussie je ne pourrais pas
faire ce que je fais sans toi dans mon écouteur
tête dans le tunnel nous en avons trois qui
arrivent imaginez quel délicieux COO c'est
très moelleux vous mangez une serviette
juste en train de nettoyer ma palette
personne ne rejoint la CIA si  J'allais être
cet incroyable espion Je suis juste la même
personne ennuyeuse que j'étais avant que tu ne le joues
trop prudemment Je viens de la voix de ma mère
abandonner ton rêve Susan juste pour écrire que
dans ma boîte à lunch Rayna Boyanov est sur le point de
vendre un nucléaire tactique  arme à une
organisation terroriste vous a dit de
m'envoyer là-bas vous ne pouvez pas
elle connaît l'identité de tous nos agents
nous avons besoin de quelqu'un pour trouver la bombe sans
être détecté je vais le faire d'accord merci
déjeuner madame vous allez d'accord ouais apportez
un de vos chats comme acolyte je n'ai pas de
chats allez voir Patrick il a
un équipement spécial pour vous on vous
donnera une nouvelle identité
ok mesdames il manque une chemise qui dit
je n'ai jamais senti le toucher d'un homme
[Musique]
c'est un constructeur de confiance
que vous pensez vraiment que vous êtes  prêt pour le terrain à
quitter l'action ce soir à ne pas entrer
en contact direct avec l'une des cibles
Je suis un vrai espion une fois que vous avez conduit une voiture sur
une autoroute au sommet d'un train alors qu'il était
en feu pas la voiture que j'étais en feu  Je
commence à me faire flipper un peu
pathétique Susan mon père avait l'habitude d'amener des
gens ici tu t'habilles aussi comme
un dresseur de dauphins [ __ ] ai-je oublié de te
frapper